hi there today we'll look at
underspecification presents challenges
for credibility in
modern machine learning by alexander
d'amour catherine heller
dan moldovan and literally all of google
all of google is on this paper including
some others
including mit and google with a white
space
but there is a lot of authors here
and not sure what they all contributed
but the
main authors are three main authors
which i guess is
legit um but this more looks like
some kind of a physics paper from cern
but we'll dive into what the paper
claims
it's sort of a paper that looks
at a higher level onto machine learning
pipelines
but gives very concrete examples for
what it's talking about
so the problem that the paper identifies
is
this thing they call under specification
which is sort of related to problems we
had in the past or
that were identified in the past but
they make a clear
distinction of what under-specification
is to what problems it leads and how
that manifests and and
also what the causes are to an extent um
well is a very long paper i think it's
some 30 pages long the main text or so
so we won't go through all of it i'll
pick out some parts of
where i think are relevant to the main
story i'll criticize it a bit because i
think
the it warrants a bit of criticism and
yeah that's what we'll do
so bear with me if you like
what videos like this don't hesitate to
share them out
and tell your friends about it also let
me know what you think
in the comments uh this is i think this
is a good topic for
you know discussing things um the
question to keep in mind while going
through this paper
is do they really uh
demonstrate what they claim so that
that was my kind of question when going
through some of this
so let's let's actually just dive into
the the abstract they say ml models
often exhibit unexpectedly
poor behavior when they are developed
deployed
in real world domains i think we we all
get a sense of what
that means and we all know of examples
when ml models
perform fine in our lab in our training
data
and test data actually but then when we
deploy them into the world
they're not doing so fine they say we
identify underspecification as a key
reason
for these failures they're not saying
it's the key
reason it's a key reason so that's the
um important
thing now they define it they say an ml
pipeline is underspecified
when it can return many predictors with
equivalently strong held out performance
in the training domain
under specification is common in modern
ml pipelines
such as those based on deep learning so
i think this the sentence isn't really
complete here
so it's underspecified when it can
return many predictors with equivalently
strong held out performance so what that
means is
you have some sort of a test set right
big data set
uh sorry train you have a big training
data set
you train your model on that and then
you test it on a
test set and the training and the test
set they usually come from some sort of
distribution
and what often happens is you simply
split your data into a train
and test it and with that you measure
this some sort of
generalization capability right so there
are a number of assumptions here namely
that
these uh this is sort of an iid
distributed data cloud
and the assumption is basically that the
test data
the data to which your model will be
applied
in the real world is sort of similar to
the data you've trained it on and if
that is the case
then a procedure like this will give you
a fairly good estimate
of how your model is going to perform in
practice however
you then take that model and you deploy
it to the real world
and the real world i look i'm horrible
at drawing real worlds but
in the real world you might have this is
europe yay
africa in the real world you might have
very different distributions of data
and the model might not perform as well
anymore
so this of course they're not the first
ones to notice
this particular problem the fact that
there's distribution shift and so on
what they are saying is that this
procedure up here
let's say it's a deep learning system
there are many
many local minima of that deep learning
system
so that starts from you know your choice
of optimizer your choice of
batch size hyper parameters the choice
of architecture
of your network and so on so there are a
number of
hyper parameters let's call them all
hyper parameters even like
the different procedures and so on so
there number of hyper parameters
learning rate
architecture um the
batch size all kinds of stuff
and what they experiment here with is
the most the most
innocuous of hyper parameters which is
the random seed
so even if everything else stays the
same and you switch up the random seed
you necessarily go into a different
local minimum right all of these give
you different models we know that
in deep learning you have sort of a
a lot of local minima actually like you
have a continuum of local minima
they are all as good as each other
and notably so these are training models
notably they all perform
quite well on that test data set right
so you train any of these models maybe
you
switch up the random seed and most of
them will actually work
quite well on the iid test data set
however they will exhibit very very
different performance when you apply
them to the real world so maybe this
model here you apply to the real world
and it works equally it also works well
but maybe this model right here
you apply it to the real world it all of
a sudden doesn't work
so the under specification problem that
they identify is when all the models
work well all the models from your
training procedure
work equally well on the test set
however they perform very differently in
the real world
namely there would actually be
a at least one model like this one here
that
does perform well even in the real world
however
there is another one at least one other
that doesn't perform
well like this so the pipeline is
underspecified
this train test split simply doesn't
capture the variation that
some important property of the real
world
so the pipeline that produces the model
is doesn't care about that feature so
it's pretty much
random whether or not that feature will
be included
or excluded or important or not
important
and it pretty much depends on which
local minima you happen to be in
and just by looking at the test set you
can't differentiate whether or not
that model will perform well in the real
world or
not this is under specification it's
very different
from the usual domain shift argument
usually you say
well the test set simply isn't
the same as the real world and therefore
the model performs well on the test set
but then in the real world
not so much right here it's more
specific you say
there would be one of these uh good
models that we get out of this procedure
one of the random seeds would actually
work well in the real world
however another one doesn't
so of course that is a problem and
they um so the the way they go about the
paper is
they say they give some examples
of how that is and in my opinion
the examples don't really convince me
like i see their point
however the examples are
let's say half convincing and then at
the end they they give some
recommendations for i mean there is some
work
in this um namely what you have to do is
you have to add constraints right
if you want to solve this problem
there's two ways either you can test
models you can take all of the models
that come out of your pipeline
test each one of them uh on the real
world on the things you care about
and the one that works you know you
deploy that however
it means that you you then again need
some kind of test data set
from that real world the other way is to
actually
since the model is underspecified try to
bring in
more specification that you care about
during the training pipeline making sure
that
um this model that you care about is the
one that
actually turns out to be returned
they don't demonstrate this here so this
is
my criticism they don't they don't they
demonstrate the problem
i think they demonstrate the problem in
a way that doesn't convince me
they also do not demonstrate a solution
so they don't
ever go ahead and say now we actually
perform this additional specification
and look what turns out is still
a good performing model but with that
thing fixed
they don't do that um yeah so that's
keep an eye out for that so we'll go as
i said through
the paper um but first a bit more of the
abstract so you just
hear it in their words they say
predictors returned by underspecified
pipelines are often treated
as equivalent based on their training
domain performance
but we show that there that such
predictors can behave
very differently in deployment domains
this ambiguity ambiguity can lead to
instability and poor model behavior and
practice
and is a distinct failure mode from
previously identified issues from
arising from structural mismatch between
training and deployment domains so
that's what i said it's
it's a different problem than the
classic domain shift or or data drift or
whatever
you might want to call it
we show that this problem appears in a
wide variety of practical ml pipelines
using examples from computer vision
medical imaging yada yada
our results show that the need to
explicitly account for under
specification in modeling pipelines
that are intended for real world to play
deployment in any domain i mean yeah
fair enough uh
this is actually a problem right and uh
you you
if you deploy ml in the real world you
would be you know it it's very
appropriate to actually care about these
types of problems i'm not saying you
shouldn't care about this
um yeah so let's go
to let's go to actually jump in
the first example so they have this
notion of what they call a stress
test okay so a stress test
is as i understand it is nothing else
than
you test whether or not you test like
one particular aspect of the model so
they're going to have
a couple of examples one example they
have an nlp
pipeline where you're supposed to
you know infer i don't know do pronoun
resolution
and the stress test one of the stress
tests would be
whether or not that model is sensitive
to gender stereotypes
okay so the the the assumption is kind
of
pronoun resolution should be like just
linguistic
thing it shouldn't really have any bias
towards
any gender stereotypes and whatnot um or
maybe not
overly so if you compare it to actual
world biases
and the stress test would be let's
measure that particular dimension so
this this gender stereotype dimension
in the model and see how that performs
so that's the the stress test and what
we are specifically
looking for is um is there a large
variance
so is there models that behave the same
on the training
and the test set but have a large
variance
in these stress tests so the first model
here
is this epidemiological model so they
say a simple epidemiological model
which appropriate for our times i guess
specifies how disease how infectious
disease moves
through a population given certain
parameters right
so um there are two parameters
you can see the differential equations
right here there are two parameters
namely there is this beta right here
represents the transmission rate of the
disease from the infected to susceptible
populations
and the parameter d which is this thing
here
represents the average duration that an
infected individual
remains infectious so once you plug in
those parameters and you start with like
some
this is some some initial population i
guess the susceptible
population this s is susceptible i
is um infected and r
is recovered so you start with a hundred
percent
susceptible and then you let this and
zero infected zero recovered you let
this play out and you see
how well that works so this is a model
and it will give you curves like this
okay so you can see depending on the
d parameter and the beta parameter you
have different curves like this they all
sort of look like this so here is number
of infected at the beginning it's zero
and then of course it like it shoots up
and but then as
kind of herd immunity i guess kicks in
uh
this goes down again so it's a quite a
simple model
and um what their goal is here they say
look let's say just hypothetically
hypothetically this is the beginning of
a pandemic
just making this up and i give you some
data points right so at the beginning
we're at zero
then we have sum then some more and then
some more
now please predict the trajectory
of the of this epidemic
from these data points so what you want
to do is you want to
fit these two parameters to the data
points there is actually a
unique solution however because of the
exponential rise
of the trajectory the
unique the solution is numerically not
well specified okay so they say
importantly during the early stages of
an epidemic
when the observations are small the
parameters of the model are
under specified by this training task
this is because at this stage
the number of susceptible is
approximately constant
at the at the total population size
as the total oh at the total population
so that means if you have a
low number of infected people the amount
of people that could get infected is
still
like pretty much everyone there is no no
type of of
of herd immunity yet and the number of
infections grows approximately
exponentially at
this rate so you can see that
approximately approximately what you're
dealing with is this
rate right here you can see both
parameters are
in this rate so if you derive some
number for this let's say this
you you derive from your data points
that this must be five
this is the rate at which the
exponential curve grows
there are many settings of beta and d
that make this number five
right in fact there are infinitely many
pairs that
make this number b5 so
they say this is a classic example of
under specification okay there are many
different uh predictors each of which
returns a good predictor on the data
that you have
and you can actually you could split
this into train and test
you could split these data points you
can say i'll take three data points as a
train and one as a test and still
there would be many many predictors that
are fit the data here you see
two of them so the blue and the red they
fit the data
equally well um right here however they
have obviously very different
trajectories
so they say this is an example of under
specification and
here already like i half agree i mean
yes
yes if you do it like this numerically
these look
kind of similar but it's like clearly
one fits more than the other
right um so i'm
i'm not sure that that is is a good
example
for this under specification but
we can you know we you can give you can
give kind of the
the benefit here and say okay they want
to give a simple model so
this is one of these models where it's
under specified
so it performs well on this data but
then if you look at this data
um it performs drastically
differently right that's that's the
important part here is drastically
different so
if the real trajectory of the of the
epidemic
is something like this
then there is a predictor namely
equal 28 that actually performs well
right it's not that that training setup
is different from the real world it's
that the variance of predictors
is so large with respect to the data
over here
that there might be some that perform
well but the others perform
pretty pretty poorly and they say this
is not only
this is not only the case for you know
this initial fit
but if you do the same and you simply
use a different
initialization so you differ simply use
uh
a different initialization for your
parameters namely you either use a gamma
or a normal distribution
that will already turn out to give you
very different results so
here
depends on where it was initialized and
different initialization distribution
result in different distribution of
predicted trajectories
so this is much more i feel an example
of what they want to demonstrate
so here depending on how you initialize
the model
the resulting model that it tends to
give you right they do
many different runs right here and you
can clearly see
that the blue curves uh that were
initialized with a normal distribution
are in general kind of on average
significantly lower
than the red curves right same data same
procedure
same everything uh but you get
in expectation even different outcomes
simply by how you initialize the
parameters this is i feel this is a very
good example
right here of what they want to say not
so much the
early training data but you get the
point
that that they say the
underspecification
uh leaves this variance
okay now what would a good
specification look like so in this case
a good specification a good would either
be
that you somehow know you somehow have a
theoretical reason for choosing
one of these two initializers this could
one
specification be that could solve the
problem another one that
is probably more practical one would
simply be to incorporate data from over
here
and thereby you you know which model you
should pick which
in an epidemic it's not really it's like
well
i can tell you how it turns out once i
know how it turns out right
um yeah so
and that that's a bit of a problem
because it already shows you sometimes
adding these more specifications or
checking
checking whether or not the model does
what you want it to do
in this specific axis
that has a large variance is just not
possible
like here but the example
is you know it's it's the example so the
next thing they do is they analyze this
in a theoretical model so they have this
theoretical model right here this is
kind of a two-layer neural network
where the first layer is completely
random okay
this is a random this is not trained
what's trained is this thing
right here so it's sort of kind of a
linear model
it's a it's sort of a model of a neural
network that people often use in
theoretical
analysis you assume some kind of
distribution on the data and then you
assume some kind of distribution
on the weight matrix um
on the weight matrix entries and then
all you do is you train the
theta parameter right here and you can
make some theoretical statements about
what happens with that model
so their goal here is to show
that
their their goal is to show the
following
what is obviously let's let's say we
keep the same data okay we keep the same
data distribution or the same
data um
we sample this w right here now
we can imagine w1 w2 w3 these are all
different weight matrices
okay so can we come up with a model
that performs well on all the weight
matrices
that we would kind of throw at it um
but that doesn't but um if we if we just
plug in kind of
different data it doesn't it stops
performing well in one particular axis
right so as long as we as long as we
only look at the training distribution
we're fine but then there is this one
particular axis
that the model just fails for some
weight matrices but not for others
okay so that's that's going to be the
theoretical goal here is to construct as
closely as possible
a model that conforms to the to the
claims right here
so what they do is they make use of
adversarial perturbations
where they say we can construct
we construct a weight matrix
where is it we construct a weight matrix
here for any given way matrix a shift
can be chosen such that
it has a small norm so that it's
essentially the same data that goes into
the model
two it leaves the risk of an
independently sampled w
mostly unchanged which is exactly what
we
you know what we have specified
is that if i simply evaluate if i train
the model
and i simply evaluate it on my original
data
then everything's fine okay but
it drastically increases the risk of w0
so what it says is
that if i have such a model like i have
above
then i can construct a situation
where i pick i simply pick one weight
matrix
say this one right here i can derive a
data set
x0 or x let's call that x3 for w3
i can derive a data set x3 such that
all the other weight matrices will work
just fine on that data set
right they will work the same as my
original data right here
everything's fine however
this particular one won't work on that
data set and that is going to that is
going to result from an adversarial
perturbation targeted
yet exactly that so this this thing here
constructs
a data set that is according to
their own claims okay so
it's a cool thing to show that this is
possible if you have an
overspecified model you can generally
do you can generally construct a
situation that exactly conforms
to their claims however i
i this is cool in theory but
i don't think they demonstrate this too
much in the real examples right here
so um yeah
just just maybe this was unclear i'm not
the best at explaining this
this type of stuff but what you can
imagine
is that the weight matrices that you get
out of your training procedure they can
be fairly different right let's just
call them vectors so this is w1 this is
w2
w3 w4 if your neural network just had
two
two different weights so the weight
matrices can be drastically different
and the solutions to them can be
drastically different but i can
construct a kind of an adversarial data
set
that is let's say exactly
um into the this is going to be very
simplified exactly into the let's say
opposite direction of one particular
um weight matrix so that it will work
just fine with this weight matrix it
will work just fine with this
with this because you have kind of um
the projection onto them
is well specified but if i try to
project it onto
this one maybe i should have drawn it
exactly orthogonal
but you get what i mean i can sort of
target one of these models
and then by definition
that one particular model that is as
good as all the other models on the
regular data
will fail for this particular data set
whereas all the other models will still
work just fine
it's kind of a theoretical analysis by
construction
yeah cool but you know
if you make a claim and then you
construct a situation that exactly
conforms to your claims
then of course it's going to conform to
your claims
um yeah so
this is more according to the real world
so this is a
medical genomics example where
you can see the training the training
data
um they have training data they have
evaluation data that comes from the same
distribution
and then they have evaluation data that
comes
out of distribution so this is more like
a domain drift domain
shift example okay and our
question is going to be how do these
things relate
so you can see that if you train on the
training data and then you evaluate on
the training data
you get this is mean squared normalized
mean squared error so lower is better
you get kind of a variance of models so
these are all the models that kind of
come out of the training procedure
and the red dot is
a specific heuristic uh that
that performs just a bit better this is
actually it's
so what it does is you have a bunch of
data points but the data points
sort of form clusters and what these
methods do is they take
one representative out of each cluster
like so
one representative and then they train a
model just on the
representatives and that's supposed to
just because these data points are all
very correlated if they're in the same
cluster that kind of gives a better
performance the red dot simply is a very
special heuristic to choose that
representative
whereas uh the the blue dots here simply
choose these representatives at random
so you can conceivably say that all
these models
like the difference is simply how these
representatives are selected and you can
see they all turn out
fairly similar with the red dot being
just a little bit
better if you go to the test
set on the same data you can see the
performance drops
but you know still everything performs
like pretty well the range of
performance here
is fairly small so all of these models
you would say they perform pretty
okay-ish
but now you go to the sets that say
out-of-distribution data and the range
of performance is just very very big
and the point here i think they're
trying to make is that
look at the best performing models right
here look at them
they are on the level of the
performance of your models in the test
data set in the in
distribution test data set however not
all of them right
so the a good performing model would be
in the models that you get but you
simply can't tell from just
looking at the test data set and that
that is according to their claim um
and they have a further graphic right
here where they show look
it's not it's not as easy as saying
uh the let's just take the best one here
because that's
going to be the best one here so here a
plot
they compare how well a model does
and the eval set uh in distribution
versus the eval set
out of distribution and you can see the
correlation
is if it's there it's fairly weak so you
like you would expect some line like
this if
that was just stretched out right if
this thing was just
stretched you would expect like a line
but here
there's just no way to tell for this
particular
data set okay so that's that's
an example of what they mean by under
specification
however i like i i fail
to see like i see that
these low points right here are kind of
on the level of the
test distribution but
i am not like
i failed to see what the difference is
to a classic
data drift just because they are on the
left on the same level right
i i don't think it's that different like
here the mean performance simply drops
and the variance
between the models increases and if i
had a different eval set
the ordering would be different and it
would look the same but the ordering of
models would be different and so on
um what you'd have to do
to for me like you i wonder
for example is it the case in this step
as well
so what here what here if you did the
same analysis
would it turn out that what performs
well in the training data set
also performs well in the test data set
or is it also pretty
pretty random from the training data set
to predict
the at least the order of test set
performance they never
do anything like this if this is
substantially different here
then you can make an argument well this
is a different thing than simply
some sort of generalization this is
really kind of due to this under
specification
because going from this data set to this
data set you sort of have a different
spec but to me it seems
that this is just kind of a domain drift
problem um and if you look closely
actually the performance right here is
lower than the best performance here
right so that this technically does not
fall under their
definition if you go strictly so
i'm not really sure what to make of
these
sort of examples um
i get what they're trying to say but it
seems to me
that except for the theoretical thing
where they construct
the examples it doesn't convince me that
it's not just domain drift okay
like it's not just the same problem that
other people have described
and secondly it also doesn't convince me
that
adding the specification will solve the
problem because
in the experiments so far notice we have
never
seen a method from them to say let's
just
fix the problem let's add the
specification and then we show
that we can really keep this performance
right the key thing is you want to keep
this performance
but you want to bring this performance
up right
um so far we've had these kind of
fundamental trade-offs and these have
often arised in let's say explainability
or fairness and so on or
actually domain adaptation is if you
want to bring this down
um a natural effect is going to be to
bring
this up so you know even if
there are good models right here it
might be
that to in order to reach those models
you actually have to weaken
um the the training procedure in order
to consistently reach those models
this is not demonstrated in the paper
that this is even
possible okay so they have a bunch of
more
case studies uh for example they have
this kind of
imagenet c example
where imagenet c kind of takes imagenet
and applies a bunch of random but
let's say well specified perturbations
on
it and again they show they show the
same thing right here they show that
look all these models they perform
uh relatively equally on the just
plain test set of imagenet but the span
of these models they are trained
all the same just the random seed is
different right
um and they they have a
huge span of performance on these
individual things and what you'll notice
also
here or here is that it's it's not
always the same model so the model that
is
uh good at the pixelate thing will be
not so good at the the contrast thing
and and so on so the question is going
to be
which the paper also doesn't solve is
going to be that
you know these kind of stress tests they
are in very very specific things like
pixelate i can think of a million
perturbations to images that are
kind of orthogonal to pixelate it
is going to be very impossible to
specify all of them right to remove this
underspecification so the question is
is probably by adding the specification
of pixelate you simply
uh worsen the problem for
any of the other things that you have
still not specified plus you probably
worsen a little bit your performance on
the actual
test set if you incorporate that into
training so the paper still hasn't shown
that that is even even possible
what is interesting is yeah here they
basically say you cannot
predict the performance on one of these
perturbations from the others
so they appear to be completely um
orthogonal so
it's not just enough to have a bunch of
perturbations
and then kind of be confident that the
model
is sort of robust to all the
perturbations
i think the core message of the paper is
that if you care about a specific
axis you have to go and check for
that specific axis right
otherwise you don't know what your model
is doing it could be
doing something good but it could be
doing something bad
if you don't specifically care about it
they do the same thing with
kind of these skin lesions so they they
have all kinds of demonstration here
in nlp they they do
tests with uh bert so and this is
interesting because
not only do they test different seeds
for
fine-tuning bird but they also test
different seeds for pre-training so in
in these language models you have like a
pre-training phase
and then you have a fine-tuning phase
and both of them have kind of random
seeds so
they're going to show that even let's
say the random seed of the pre-training
will actually already play a big role in
how these models um perform in these
stress tests uh i find i find this to be
pretty interesting so they do this with
respect to these
gender data sets which have been
constructed to sort of assess fairness
of these models and so
what you're going to have is data like
the following so you'll you're going to
have to
the sentence let's say a doctor is
walking
so it's always going to be like some
sort of profession okay
used in a sentence and then
what you do is you simply replace that
entity
with a man or a woman
right you replace it twice and you ask
your model you perform you embed all of
these sentences
and then you ask your model how similar
are those sentences i presume by simply
taking the inner product
of the um of the
embeddings or you can actually train it
okay so they say part of glue our
ensemble of predictors achieve
consistent accuracy
measured in terms of correlation with
human-provided
similarity scores ranging from this to
that
okay so so you have kind of a model that
can predict similarity in text
just similarity it has it does not it
knows nothing about gender right you
simply train it on a data set
to predict similarity
in text and then you ask it so this
sentence that i have here this reference
sentence is it
more similar to when i replace the
entity with a woman
or is it more similar to when i replace
the entity with
a man okay and what you look at is the
the difference between the two so if
this is a
positive number that means that
the sentence is more similar to when you
replace it with
the word woman and when you have a
negative number
the the same for men and if the model is
let's say insensitive to the gender
dimension
then you expect a difference here of
zero
at least in expectation right so
a model that does not learn a gendered
correlation for a given profession
will have an expected similarity delta
of zero
we are particularly interested in the
extent to which the similarity delta for
each profession correlates
with the percentage of women actually
employed in that profession
as measured by us bureau of labor
statistics
right this is uh in my opinion this is
already an improved
um assessment from what usually happens
in these
in these fairness literature things
where they just say
well if it's anything but 50 50 we are
angry
um which i get i get it if you you know
some cases you need to build a model
that is actually 50 50.
but if if you want to
assess things like they assess here like
the question the question is does the
model
spuriously pick up this thing so if
the model does something like if the
model
is let's say perfect um and does only
the task we
need it to do it will learn the
association between a profession and the
gender
in the exact proportion that it kind of
happens
in the text which i guess is
proportional to the proportion at which
it happens
in the world if however
the model for some reason uses this
thing as a feature
more or less than it should then we see
a discrepancy
and why is that important that it's
important because if we then deploy this
model
right we we simply take so the model
here is going to be
the axis here is going to be zero zero
and
the model can perfectly solve the task
by simply being here right it's actually
best to be
here where this delta uh between
the similarity and the profession
percentage is zero
but the model can probably solve the
task equally well by being here
or here or here or here right it can
solve the task equally well
however if we just happen to pick at the
end we pick one model if we happen to
pick this model right here
that model just by more or less chance
has a much higher association with one
gender to particular professions than
the other
and depending on what we use the model
for like we seldomly use the model
on the exact task and data that we
trained it on
depending on what we use it for this
might cause some some adverse effects
okay so i want to stress that this is
not the same
as your kind of classic fairness
literature this
really considers all these models they
perform like equally well
on the test set of that particular task
and
since it's overspecific or
underspecified over parameterized
there are many many ways to solve tasks
some of these ways will include
this feature some of these ways will
include actually the opposite feature
and if we kind of pick one that's at the
extreme
then the model is going to have that
feature and that might not that might
not be
important for this task but it might
cause something bad
for a task that we ultimately apply it
on
so they do this similarity and they do
pronoun resolution
and um so they come up with different
things they say there is a large
spread in correlation with bls
statistics
on the sts test correlations range from
0.3 to 0.7
on the pronoun resolution task the range
is this
as a point of comparison prior work on
gender shortcut pronoun resolution found
correlation ranging for that
okay so we are in the in the same
ballpark as
prior work they say there is a weak
relationship
between test accuracy performance and
gendered correlation
um so there's a spearmint correlation
coefficient for
of 0.08 which is a weak correlation
right
in fact the confidence interval includes
zero
oh that's for pronoun resolution so for
for the is for the similarity it's 0.21
which is
an okay correlation the confidence
interval just barely includes zero
so we're fairly sure i'm not a
statistician don't grill me about p
values
uh this they say this indicates that
learning accurate predictors does not
require
learning strong gendered correlations
which is a statement you can make
though i would say such a overs
over parameterized underspecified model
will probably pick up
this feature here fairly often since the
correlation
is there right but they are right it
does not require
it does not require strong correlations
okay and they say the encoding of
spurious correlation is sensitive to the
random seed at pre-training
and not just fine tuning so this is very
interesting especially in the pronoun
resolution tasks the pronoun resolution
test
don't want to go into it too much here
but so here you can see
two different runs so two different um
random seeds
that result in two very different
so here is the similarity delta this is
this this
minus this we observed before plotted
against this percentage
female by occupation for individual
occupations
and you can see here um this predictor
has a stronger correlation than this
predictor right here
now i've thought about it i'm i'm still
not sure which one is let's say
let's call it the better one because um
um yeah i'm not sure like because the
you can say the bottom predictor has
less of a correlation
with actual occupation
i think that makes it worse
right but you might argue that
a model just shouldn't depend or
shouldn't care
but then the delta is not zero whereas
this top
predictor actually has the zero here at
fairly at the point where it's 50 50.
so i'm going to tacitly argue that the
top predictor is the one you want but
i i don't know the important part the
paper doesn't make a strong opinionated
claim about which one you want the paper
actually just says
you should be aware that both predictors
solve the task very well
however one th they're drastically
different
in how they treat this feature so here
you can see
there's not really a correlation between
this score and and the tested accuracy
you can't tell from the test set
what you know you can't tell from the
test set how it's going to perform
in this particular stress test
and this is very interesting in the
pronoun resolution task
they here they plot by different
pre-training seeds and you can see they
clearly cluster
right so even the pre-training seed
has an influence later on this on this
performance
i guess it's kind of logical but it's
still interesting to see that this
clusters so well uh while all these
things
solve the task um the same so
that it basically means that you can't
just take like a bird checkpoint and
then fine tune it with like an objective
in there that
um you might already be worried about
how the pre-training happened i guess
maybe you can fix it i know that's what
they don't show
so they analyze it a bit more they say
they take 20 of those predictors
here to better understand the
differences between predictors in our
example
we analyze the structure in how
similarity scores produced by the
predictors in our ensemble deviate from
the ensurable mean
here we find that the main axis of
variation aligns at least in its
at its extremes with differences in how
predictors represent
stereotypical associations between
profession and
gender so these data sets by the way
they are annotated
um you know they are constructed such
that the kind of stereotypes
manifest or don't manifest depending on
how much your model has picked those up
during training um specifically
we perform principal component analysis
over
similarity score produced by 20 fine
tunings of a single birth checkpoint
so 20 different models we plot the first
principal component which contains 22
percent of the variation in score
deviations against the female
participation percentages in figure
9. notably examples in the region where
the first principal component
values are strongly negative include
some of the strongest
gender imbalances so let's look at this
graphic right here because this this is
where i kind of
sort of get skeptical okay so let's
understand
these plots on the left right here so
what you have
is the first principal component of this
kind of
of this resulting similarity scores
so i'm going to guess each of these dots
here
is one of these models um
so you can see and i'm going to guess
that each of these
line is like one of these professions
okay
so for a given profession like this this
here appears to be a profession where
let's say approximately
that has a 20 female participate
occupation rate
and the spread here is going to be how
the
different models happen to
um to manifest in the first principle
component so the first principal
component
you know the axis of largest variation
in the data set
so the first thing that is very notable
here is that
these models are spread out quite a bit
right so they are
they are they they perform like
sometimes it's very
uh the it's very negative sometimes it's
very positive for the same thing right
this is
uh what is strange or
this is a thing that this paper points
out all these models
perform equally well on the test set of
the task
that they care about however so this
here
is when you put men as a subject so up
the honda these occupations that
are listed here would be something like
i don't know
mine mine worker oil rig worker or
something like this
and on the bottom you'd have kind of the
more stereotypical female
professions like a nurse or something
like this
so a couple of things to note here
so what they what they do is the red
dots here are theirs
so they say we'll take the extremes and
the extremes are just
whenever i think this is here is
negative one
so they take the extremes and they look
at them here and they
kind of make a point of the first
principal component
in its extremes displays
kind of the most most anti-stereotypical
examples okay so it you have to see
here is these dots are where the first
principle component
is loaded negatively by a lot
and the sentences these are the red dot
sentences right there
red dots those are those sentences a
receptionist is crawling
is the sentence and the plot is for man
as a subject
so this is the when measure when you
measure the similarity between
a receptionist is crawling and a man
is crawling you ask
how how similar are those sentences
compared to
when i enter a woman is crawling
sorry compared to the similarity of a
receptionist is crawling with a woman is
crawling
right so this is the the data this is
fairly it's really meta
right so their claim is
that this first principle component kind
of um
incorporates this feature by
a lot and i think their their point is
kind of see even when we don't train
this stuff there are models that
um that very much rely on kind of these
or that very much over rely
uh on these kind of stereotypes however
that this is very i feel it's
it's a bit it's a bit shady because
i mean look at look at this data right
you can't like you can't just pick
these outliers like here these are
outliers too and even if you look here
like they
conveniently pick um
so i guess they conveniently pick such
that these things here are left out you
can see here
it's woman as a subject so what you'd
expect
here if this is really the models pick
up a lot of these
kind of um spurious correlation what
you'd expect
is a line like this right you have like
shift here and then
up here because you know 100 women like
the first component will load a lot
you don't see that at all right and here
you see a little bit
you see a little bit a slope like this
but i don't think that just and
especially if you look at the noise
between the things like this is here
and then this is over here right so like
the in-between noise
is way bigger um to go and claim yeah
the first principal components contain
something like this and then
we don't look at these outliers up here
i
i don't know um
yeah so this this doesn't seem to me
like i see what they're trying to say
and what is concerning is that there is
such a big spread
among the models right within these
professions there is a giant spread
these are the same performing models
so i see the
what they're trying to say but i don't
think the point they're making here
i don't know if this is politics or
something that they have to kind of
bring in
these these types of topics but you know
they also look at
with respect to others and they show
look
uh these models perform differently with
respect to different
stress test dimensions and notably the
ordering
isn't the same but again i feel that
this is simply
this might be just a problem of domain
uh shift rather than what they're
claiming
and lastly they have a kind of a
a test on these other stress tests
there are also nlp stress tests and you
can
see that the models perform quite
differently so there's a spread right
here
within each of these the red bar is the
spread
on the actual test set as i understand
it
and then these are the different um
pre-training seeds and you can
again see that even the pre-training
seed will
have a big effect right here so
yeah again um what i would like to see
is kind of
how does the even does even the training
performance
predict the test performance on the same
distribution that would already be
quite informative as you can see right
here you can't really predict one of
these stress tests
from the other um the question is just
can you even do this for the training to
the test set because
that would inform you whether or not
this is a property
of this stress test being in a different
direction
uh one direction that you didn't capture
if if these stress tests are really
meant to show that look
you can't really tell this axis that you
didn't specify this is really
because of under specification you would
expect
that from the training performance you
could at least predict the test
performance somewhat or from the test
performance you could predict
on an iid test set i'm going to assume
that it is somewhat like this but i
also not sure that you like that this is
anything
to rely on and the last thing they do is
kind of a lab study
where they have kind of vital signals
and they predict
um whether or not there is a medical
problem
and again you can see here they even
test different architectures and so on
and what they're basically the point is
the point is the same
but it's just shown in a different date
it's pretty cool that they have
lots of different different examples
right here but i don't want to go into
the
lab thing so their discussion at the end
i think is kind of kind of weak because
i mean what they say is
our findings underscore uh
the need to thoroughly test models on
application specific tasks
and in particular to check that the
performance on these tasks is stable
i mean i fully agree with that right if
you if you deploy your model into some
sort of
real-world application please test
whether it actually
works in that real world application but
it seems to me that that is not
it's not a solution uh fully
to the problem because as we saw in the
epidemiology
paper that sometimes just isn't possible
um and also you know
it is the case that not everyone can
train a language model so we kind of
need pre-trained checkpoints maybe the
goal is that
we provide like maybe google if they
provide one birth checkpoint
let's say they provide uh 50
right and then people can go ahead and
check which one actually is good or bad
on on their particular dimension that
they care about that maybe the
pre-training
didn't care about that would i think
that would be a practical
solution to the problem if you
can't specify it and what i would say
also is that it's not clear to me
that it is always possible even you know
in theory maybe but it is not clear to
me that it is
always possible to add the specification
that you want
and keep the same performance i see that
there are predictors
in the set that they consider that have
that but that doesn't mean
that once you add the constraint the
training procedure
reaches that same performance and
specifically it keeps the performance on
the test set
so that's kind of a number of criticisms
on this paper
all in all i mean it's it's a paper that
you generally can agree
with right can agree with the the
sentiment and also the analysis
the examples are of course real and the
problem is real
and uh yeah especially for a company
like google this is
fairly important because they build big
models and deploy big models
all right let me know what you think
about this i'll see you next time bye